نقلت القناه الثثالث عش الاسرائيليه عن
مسؤول اسرائيلي قوله ان اسرائيل لم تتلقى
ردا بعد من حماس بشان صفقه التبادل وانها
تتوقع وصول الرد من قطر في غضون الساعات
القريبه وذكرت القناه الاسرائيليه عن
المسؤول نفسه ان هناك تفاؤلا بشان امكانيه
تحريك الصفقه رغم ان الاعلان عن انها
ستبدا مطلع الاسبوع المقبل كان سابقا
لاوانه حسب تعبيره وقالت القناه الثانيه
عش الاسرائيليه ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ابلغ عائلات
الرهائن انه سيقر صفقه لا تضر بامن
اسرائيل وان ادت لانهيار حكومته واكدت ان
المبادره التي تم بحثها في لقاء باريس تنص
على يوم تهدئه لقاء الافراج عن كل اسير
اسرائيلي يليها اسبوع تجري خلاله مفاوضات
على المرحله الم مقبله كما قالت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان الجانب الاسرائيلي
يبحث الافراج عن اسرى النخبه الذين
اعتقلوا خلال الحرب خلال المرحله الاولى
من صفقه
التبادل تنضم الينا من تلبيب مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان هل يبدو نتنياهو
وكانه يهيئ الراي العام لقبوله بصفقه بعد
ان يرتب اوضاع حكومته فيما لو
سقطت ليكون
يائير لابيد بديلا عن سموتريتش وبن
غفير بالفعل من الواضح انه من خلف
الكواليس يقوم نتنياهو بفعل كل شيء لضمان
بقاء حكومته من خلال هذه الاتصالات مع حزب
المعارضه الاكبر حزب يوجد مستقبل بزعامه
يائير لابيد في الوقت الذي كانت منذ يوم
امس تتحدث فيه المصادر عن بعد ان اعلن
لابيد بانه سيمنح نتنياهو شبكه امان
برلمانيه في كل ما يتعلق بالتوصل الى صفقه
تبادل كان نتنياهو مباشره يقوم بتصريحات
توحي
بانه يريد بقاء بين كفير وسموت في الحكومه
وانه لا يوجد اي مفاوضات مع حزب ايه يوجد
مستقبل من اجل الانضمام للحكومه هذا اليوم
في لقاء مع القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه ع
قالها بشكل علني لابيد بانه مستعد ليس فقط
لمنح هذه الحكومه شبكه امان برلمانيه اي
عدم التصويت على حجب الثقه وانما مستعد
للانضمام الى هذه الحكومه مقابل او مكان
سموتريتش وبين كفير من اجل اتمام هذه
الصفقه مباشره اصدر حزب الليكود بيان قال
فيه بانهم بان او اتهم عمليا لابيد بانه
يدفع باتجاه وقف لاطلاق النار وانهاء
الحرب دون تحقيق انتصار مطلق لاسرائيل وهو
ما لا يوافق عليه حزب الليكود رد بعدها
مباشره حزب يوجد مستقبل بان الهدف للبيد
هو السعي من اجل تحقيق نصر من خلال اعاده
الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه وليس انقاذ
نتنياهو وعمليا هناك الكثير من التناقضات
في التصريحات التي تصدر في حين ان يحاول
ربما لابيد التقرب من نتنياهو والدخول الى
الحكومه نتنياهو ربما من خلف الكواليس
وفقا ايضا لما نقلته وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه بانه
تم عرض حقيبه القضاء على يائير لابيد وعلى
حزبه يوجد مستقبل قبل ايام قليله من اجل
اقناعه بالانضمام الى الحكومه الا انه
بالعلن يقوم بالادلاء بتصريحات مم مختلفه
دعنا ايضا حسن فقط نشير الى هذا الفيديو
الذي نشره فقط قبل دقائق قليله بنيامين
نتانياهو عن صفقه التبادل وهي ايضا يعني
تتناقض ربما مع جا مع ما جاء بعد انتهاء
لقائه بعائلات الاسرى هذا اليوم نتنياهو
مره اخرى يقول بانه يسعى للتوصل الى صفقه
تبادل لكن ليس باي ثمن وان هناك خطوط
حمراء بالنسبه الى اليه لن يتم تجاوزها
ومن بينها وفقا لقوله انه لن يتم سحب قوات
الجيش جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من داخل
غزه ولن يوافق على وقف لاطلاق النار وايضا
لن يتم الافراج عن الاف ممن يصفه يصفهم
نتنياهو بالمخ اي الاسرى الفلسطينيين في
سجون الاحتلال هذه الليله كان هناك اشاره
من قبل في القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه عش
بان مثل هذه التصريحات لنتنياهو تسعى الى
تخريب نم وعرقل مسار التوصل الى صفقه
تبادل اسرى